l'abolition de l'esclavagé le 22 mai 10
à 40 8 en martinique et en connexion
avec celle de guadeloupe le 27 mai et de
guyane le 10 juin depuis hier tropiques
atrium propose une plateforme numérique
sur son site
avec cinq rubriques des paroles de
tutoriels des conférences homme du
cinéma de la musique et des arts visuels
cette proposition sur notre site et sur
notre facebook permet d'avoir plusieurs
entrées sur cet événement historique
répandant en connexion avec la
guadeloupe et la guyane est depuis hier
on peut donc avoir des informations sur
ces existences il s'agit de résistance
le nom de cette plateforme mettront
elles ou le concert de cali une short
list l'anomie ce que nous avions prévu
que notre programmation et que nous
avons enregistrés dans des conditions du
direct
et cette opération aussi et résistance
est un acte de solidarité puisque ça a
permis à des artistes à des internautes
heures de travail et il le projet de
fresque commanderie à quatre plasticiens
qui commande à 18h sur l'esplanade
s'inscrit dans cette dynamique donc
résistance à vivre sur le site de
tropiques attrayant autour d abolition
de l esclavage